the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license your support
will help MIT OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational resources
for free
to make a donation or view additional
materials from hundreds of MIT courses
visit MIT opencourseware at ocw.mit.edu
and yeah welcome everyone today today
we're gonna be talking about advanced
concepts these are kind of like what I
would consider the next generation of
solar cells if these ideas pin out some
of them are very near and dear to my
heart because it's what my research is
mainly focused on also another quick
realization I had last week probably
Tony I mentioned this to me at some
point but do you guys know where six to
six comes from why the course is that
called that so 6.2 or was it six point
two six times ten to the minus thirty
fourth is Planck's constant so haha
funny thought that was kind of cool so
the little joke put in there so anyhow
without further ado yeah one of the cool
things cells are done yay this is great
news I was very very happy so didn't go
quite as well as expected I think most
of you are finding out that these are
incredibly serious distance limited I'm
gonna talk about why that might be in a
second hopefully that'll help you guide
you through your analysis which we'll be
doing for the final part of the quiz 2.3
which hopefully I'll be able to post by
tomorrow afternoon ish I'm still working
on that right now but just to give you
guys kind of the the processing that you
didn't get to see this is what the
contact firing looks like it's a very
very very fast process it's really
remarkable to me that this is it
combines so many photo lithographic
steps that if you wanted to make this in
the lab using photo lithography and
condenses the six or seven steps into
one process so it's pretty remarkable so
dupont the people who made the pace so
we use pv 16 a if you guys are curious
for our front contacts for silver paste
and we actually get the really important
part as this peeking temperature and you
can see that we actually got pretty
close to the ramp times where it really
starts to deviate is here and we hold it
around 400 a little bit longer which is
several reasons for that and I'll go
into that in a second but what's
important is that all these are fired in
an oxygen atmosphere so normally in
these belt furnaces so this is again
what's used in industry this is actually
the same exact tool that I use at
Harvard it actually looks like this with
a giant CRT monitor
on top of the only way to get the data
off is with the three and a half floppy
drive I can't tell you how difficult it
was to find it working three and a half
floppy drive most of them are
demagnetized at this point I had to buy
new ones they're still being made by the
way if you want them go to Staples so
anyhow it's done in an oxygen atmosphere
so they generally force air flow into
these giant dolt furnaces and these are
really long like that's about probably
about a foot wide maybe a little
18 inches wide so this goes on for tens
of feet or several meters depending on
where you're from and it's done an
oxygen atmosphere an air atmosphere
because it needs to burn off a lot of
the binders and some of the organics
that might still be there and so those
organics burn off and what you're left
with oh the little metal particles the
frit and the some metal oxide glass it's
usually lead oxide although DuPont will
never tell you but this is from papers
I've read this is generally what's used
so when that happens so this is that
burn off period when it spikes the frit
will actually burn through your silicon
nitride layer you guys didn't have a
silicon nitride layer but if it was
there it would help eat through it and
so that way you removed the dielectric
so you can actually make contact metal
contact with your silicon surface
underneath that firing will during that
peak also simultaneously these metal
particles will melt and form this triple
eutectic point with the silicon
underneath it and with so the triple
comes from the silver the silicon in the
lead the lead actually dissociates from
the glass it is lowers the melting
temperature of that mixture and you can
make good ohmic contact with the surface
so it's actually a pretty remarkable
incredible process it's still almost
kind of magic to me on how the whole
thing works and a lot of its just kind
of guess and check and still very
proprietary so the science is still a
little lacking there you don't find a
lot of good articles explaining the
science of it I have a few if you guys
are interested NREL has put out a lot of
really interesting stuff and some of the
ways they actually figure out the actual
profile underneath the contacts versus
you measure the temperature on the side
of the contacts they're actually
touching the silicon or the silicon
nitride surface is you actually measure
hydrogen diffusion underneath it and so
they'll actually will etch
off the contacts and measure a hydrogen
using secondary ion mass spectroscopy
measured the hydrogen concentration off
the contact and underneath the contact
actually tell you what temperature it's
all based on that diffusion profile so
there is some good science going on but
there's not a lot of great papers on the
on it so anyhow that gives kind of gives
you what I was working on over the
weekend trying to get these cells fired
so I aggregated a lot of the results and
tried to make sense of what was going on
I thinks I should some of you different
firing temperatures and the fill factors
we got and there was kind of just noisy
data so I couldn't get any real trends
the best trend I could find was that if
you take the median of all the
short-circuit currents of the cells and
you look at the ones with four
millimeter and two millimeter spacing
the four millimeter spacing has a
slightly higher short-circuit current
presumably due to shading losses if you
look at the relative areas that each of
these cover up you would expect a four
percent increase this is about three
percent so I'll take that as fact it
might be and certainly within the noise
in the air of the number of samples that
we have but I thought it was interesting
nonetheless additionally I plotted the
series distance that I calculated from
your dark IV curves and plotted your
maximum power I also removed all the
cells that were broken I'm sure if I
actually normalized them there were some
some of the cells that were broken
actually performed a lot better and I'll
get into maybe why that was the case in
a second but the really the take-home
message is that are really best
performing cells are all clumped over
here and so you can see that our best
cells have a very low series distance
that's not always the case there's some
outliers like this guy here and I don't
know how that happened but so some
really interesting things going on I'm
still trying to sift through it so I
talked about this I think yesterday in
the analysis section but there's several
sources of Serio systems any you guys
familiar with what they are
emitter sheet resistance and then why
it's so there's line resistance along
the fingers and then there's contact
resistance so I'm going to draw this out
really quickly so if you have this is
your emitter you have a contact here
kind of contact here if you generate an
electron here it'll diffuse hit the
junction then it has to flow through the
emitter to the contact there's an
Associated resistance with that that's
the C resistance that we taught in class
that has to do with the emitter
resistance additionally to hop over that
metal semiconductor Junction there's
actually a resistance there that's
called a contact resistance so this is
so this is emitter and this is our
contact and then it has to travel from
the line to the busbar here and that's
our line resistance and I think what's
really limiting us because when I looked
at both the shallow and deep emitters
the series resistance didn't really have
any noticeable trends so I really think
that this is what's limiting us
completely is our contact resistance
which is kind of too bad so one of the
reasons I think that's the case
additionally is that some of the cells
that perform the best I know Jules did
particularly well I think he had a what
was your full factor do you remember
okay so one side was better so again the
in homogeneity have met doing the
measurement those also another
indication that our series isn't across
the contacts is really poor so some of
the other contacts if you look on
where's my good piece of chuck right if
here's our bus bar
some people saw delamination who saw
their contacts delaminate yeah so a
couple people and so what that means is
that these contacts actually peeled up
and that's usually showing that the
what's funny though is that these areas
in the middle didn't delaminate it was
only the edges here and so that's
showing that some parts are being
properly fired and some parts are being
under fire because when I fired at
higher temperatures I was getting
shunting and that was due to shunting
through the center area so I think that
the RTA that I was using this wasn't the
case on some of the year earlier cells I
had processed but is rather in
homogeneity in homogeneous in terms of
the temperature profile it's delivering
to our cells so I think that could be
part of our problem as well yeah it's
one at a time
and there's some variability in the peak
firing temperature I've unfortunately
with the RTA so I've learned a lot about
when we're gonna buy an RTI for a but
for our lab what to look for the
temporal resolution of the data you get
out of it and how it records it is 0.6
seconds and with this thing's ramping at
100 °c per second
your variability is quite large so the
temperature I read is not just from the
data point but I do a linear
interpolation to actually figure out
what the peak is on both sides of that
peak and it ends up being about anywhere
from 20 to 40 degrees Celsius higher
using that technique and so the
variability varies from about it's about
20 degrees plus or minus 10 degrees
Celsius in terms of what I want the peak
to be and what it actually is
so the RTA that we're using now is not
incredibly repeatable also better our
TAS will have a different heater on top
and bottom and so you can actually heat
one side more than the other and
generally belt furnaces so commercial
ones will have both will have that same
kind of control I know at 1366 that
they've actually done optimization to do
heating the top and bottom differently
because they use different pace they
have different heat requirements thermal
requirements and so nailing that
temperature and that profile actually
takes a lot of iteration and a lot of
time and it's really just learning the
tool as opposed to again good science
behind it so it's it can be rather
difficult and time-consuming to do so
that's what I have to say about the
cells
I think overall though I think the
efficiencies were on the order of six to
I think nine percent for some of the
cells so that's not too bad I'm still
rather pleased with that
so okay last time I think Tonio stopped
talking about or stopped right before he
was going to talk about performance of
modules in the field and the kind of
that what's the difference between your
cell efficiency and your module
efficiency modules are put out in the
Sun they heat up they can get shaded by
snow rain clouds trees and also the
modules are made up of many different
cells that are connected in series in
parallel and how does that affect their
overall performance of the module and so
that's we're going to talk about really
quickly so first off why does
temperature matter so all solar cells
when they're measured either at NREL or
in our lab are measured under standard
operating conditions or standard testing
conditions sorry certainly not standard
operating conditions standardized
testing conditions are done at 25 C
generally the cells are actively cooled
to maintain that temperature of room
temperature and most semiconductor
simulations you perform are generally
done at 300 Kelvin I know all the
calculations I did for fitting your non
ideal diode curve we're done at 300 K
typical operation can actually be pretty
hot so 50 to 65 degrees Celsius actually
don't know what that is in Fahrenheit
but it's hot yeah yeah it's hotter than
Phoenix and I'm sure they get even even
hotter in Phoenix okay so the effective
temperature so how is it affect vo see
if you recall this is our diet equation
we have a lumination current which we'll
get to how that's affected by
temperature in a second but for now just
ignore that assume it stays constant so
one of the things that's really
affecting your vo C so remember your vo
C is going to make your current go to
zero and the main thing that's being
altered is your your saturation current
so your intrinsic carrier concentration
your diffusivity so who here thinks your
vo C is going to go up with temperature
anyone who thinks it'll go down
who has no idea okay so who raise their
hand for it'll go down sorry Ben do you
have any ideas why that might be the
case okay so who what's gonna happen to
your eye not with increased temperature
that that should increase I not so
therefore it's gonna take a smaller
voltage to counteract I sub L to make I
equal to zero right and so why does n
sub I increase with temperature right so
it increases the number of thermally
promoted carriers and so that effect can
actually be pretty stark and now we go
to a demo yay
all right so what we have here is our
favorite solar cell this came again from
those small little toy cars
that we pulled off and again these solar
cells the cars will assume we're nothing
these are about 10 bucks apiece so
pretty cheap probably cheaper than your
solar cells that you guys made and well
certainly I know they are Qi the wafers
themselves by the way over 16 bucks
apiece so saying they were a dollar it
was a little inaccurate so anyhow we
have this hooked up to a multimeter and
we're gonna measure the voltage off of
it I'm going to illuminate it with our
desk lamp and we can actually get a
pretty decent voltage I can't actually
see this so it's about 0.5 7 volts and
now we're going to subject it to
temperature this is obviously gross
overestimation of what's actually gonna
happen but can someone read out the Joel
can you read the temperature for me
sorry the voltage
five six one and decreasing oh yeah down
to five five
so it's going down okay so
congratulations the people who said it
would go down correct hopefully that'll
cool it wow that's actually quite hot
anyhow
so that's what happens in the field so
when these temper cells heat up you
actually lose your on your vo C and if
you really want to you can go through
all the math you know what the equation
is for your vo C it's shown here and you
can go through this if you like it's all
on PV cd-rom if you want to go through
the derivation you then can take the
derivative with respect to temperature
and if you plug in values for crystal
and silicon it comes to about 2.2
millivolts per degree Celsius which
sounds like a small number but it's at
around point one volts if you go up to
65 C so that's actually quite a
substantial amount and again when you're
going from I don't know point six to
0.59 these small margins can make or
break a lot of installations so that's
an important okay now who this one's a
little harder who what do you think will
happen with your illumination current or
your ISC who thinks it's gonna go up
anyone who thinks is gonna go down who
thinks is gonna stay the same who has
absolutely no idea and didn't raise
their hand okay that's totally fine this
confused me as well by the way so when
we think about it what is our
short-circuit current proportional to
generally anyone right so generally your
illumination intensity and in what
photons generally collecting super
bandgap so what could be happening is
our bandgap could be changing I so Bell
has been pointed out should increase the
flux of photons above the bandgap and EG
actually decreases the temperature so
your bandgap actually usually increases
the true band gap of silicon to find
most properties of semiconductors are
actually defined at zero Kelvin and
semiconductors are technically
insulators because they don't conduct
electricity at zero Kelvin
they just means semiconductors a class
of materials I have a small enough
bandgap that they can thermally promote
carriers that they can actually conduct
some electricity at room temperature and
but the true band gap of silicon is
around 1.17 and as you increase
temperature you get a reduction of the
bandgap and so what should happen is
your ISC should increase but only very
very slightly so if you go over the
derivation for the actual decrease in
the overall efficiency there's a few
things one you'll take remember your
efficiency is your or your maximum power
is your vo C times your is C times your
fill factor so if you want the
derivative of your max power with
respect to temperature you need to do
the partial derivatives and sum them up
for all of those different components so
that's what this calculation is doing
and again this is what it is for fill
factor this is all in Martin greens
paper down here and also on PV cd-rom if
you guys are interested in that Martin
greens tabulated a lot of this doing
making these general expressions and
also fitting it to experimental data to
get that information and then it ends up
being not a negligible percent but point
about half a percent per degree Celsius
for silicon so if you go up by 40
degrees you can see that it's no longer
an edge temperature isn't a
non-negligible effect in terms of
performance
yes
oh that's a good point generally
temperatures a lot worse because you're
really gonna hurt your vo see your to
increase your J not tremendously with
temperature right cuz you're creating
more thermal carriers so your diffusion
current that's counteracting your
illumination current is going to
increase dramatically so temperature is
always your enemy there was a great
picture on PV cd-rom of solar
installation in Antarctica and it's
performing well buffs back which is kind
of cool so so yeah temperatures
generally an enemy and so a lot of
people's ideas have often been like to
do active cooling and use that for waste
heat and there's a lot of reasons why
that doesn't necessarily economically
make sense but when you do what's a
concentrated solar for example and I
think Tony will talk about this the next
lecture but concentrated solar is you're
putting in not just one Sun but about a
thousand maybe 10,000 Suns on one small
device and the idea there is you can
have a really small device have it be
really expensive but incredibly
efficient on the order of 40 percent
efficient because you have these stacks
of different semiconductors that absorb
different regions of the light
preferentially and those heat up
tremendously you know when you're being
subjective it's like you know an ant
under a magnifying glass or something it
just it only can burn it so they
actually have active cooling to cool
those cells and they also have to track
the Sun as well in order to concentrate
it and the last thing which you guys did
for your exam number one right was the
effect of light intensity where you
looked at light intensity throughout the
day assume some sinusoid for the
incident light and you measured how your
efficiency changes and you remember your
vo C decreases with light intensity with
your JSC and that's due to the decrease
in the photon flux and your efficiency
goes down according to those two
equations there and I think the
de-rating factor if you assume a
sinusoid that hits at one Sun and then
declines you should do rate your if you
use instead of using peak Sun if you
want to do you rate that by about twenty
percent so it's actually pretty
substantial I was kind of surprised at
that finding okay so when these cells go
out into the field they are not just in
not just one individual cell so
oftentimes your
you string these in series and then in
parallel so right now we're just gonna
look at series and in parallel slowly
and what you see here are your three
different cells all mounted in series so
the top of the cell is connected to the
bottom of this cell the top of the cell
is connected to the model this cell
our bad cell marked here with the I
guess the denim pattern I don't know
what that was in PowerPoint but what's
important here is that because the
current flowing to this one is also
flowing through this one fulfilling to
this one the voltage is add and the
currents are all matched so the current
out of this stack of cells is limited by
your weakest cell it can't exceed your
short-circuit current of your weakest
cell so you can see that your operating
point for these three cells is not ideal
for this one it's definitely way off the
peak operating point for this cell and
way off the peak operating point for
that so so it can be a pretty
detrimental effect and this is why often
an industry when you do a series of
testing on your cells you H cell gets
tested either using sons vo C or a very
very fast IV measurement you can bin
cells based on their performance and
then match them so that if you if your
all your cells are perfectly matched
they're all operating at the peak power
point you're getting the most out of all
those cells and so that's why reducing
the variability within your process can
really really increase your module
performance and that's something a lot
of companies work really really hard at
now the other reason why series is
important to study is the effect of
shading so when you decrease so let's
say a leaf falls on your solar panel or
it's partially shaded because you put it
in your trees if you look at the big
belly solar one's right near campus
they're always in shade it makes no
sense to me I think they might get one
our Sun a day in certain times of the
year anyhow so if you partially stay in
one of the cells you can see that the IV
curve drops down and now this cell is
running in Reverse bias and when you're
in reverse bias you're running a lot of
current through your shunts and for
those who were here this morning we know
that shunts are really really bad
because that's where all your currents
running through and if your current
running through one localized
spot that's where it's heating up the
most and it can heat up to temperatures
that can actually melt me and capsule in
or completely destroy the cell so this
can actually be rather destructive and
generally once your whole set your whole
your cells are made and encapsulated in
a module it's really hard to remove them
and replace that module pretty much the
whole modules kaput at that point so
it's pretty destructive so what people
generally do for there's important
things you don't want it helps it
they're angled so snow and other things
will fall off of it you don't want to
put it in areas where if next to a
chimney for example where certain parts
of the day it will be shaded or things
like that so I've seen some studies on
cleaning and it all depends of and
economically makes sense right if you
want to pay someone to clean your panels
that's expensive is it worth it for them
to do that if you're only saving just a
little bit obviously the shading is so
bad that it could detrimental II ruin to
destroy your module it's really you want
to do that ways to prevent the
destruction is actually a lot of cells
will have bypass diodes so if a string
goes down the current will just flow in
through that diode and won't destroy the
cell and so that's one way of kind of
fixing that problem that's a great
question okay okay so now we're backing
ourselves in in parallel normally again
in a module you have them in series and
then these stacks of cells in series are
actually put in parallel but this is
just an easy illustration again cells in
parallel you're matching in voltage and
the currents are what adding and so if
one cell let's say has a low output
voltage it's going to shift the max of
the operating power the operating power
point for the other two cells off of
their maximum power point and you're
going to get a reduced
output and so this is actually very
analogous to this idea that when you
make your cells larger generally that
efficiency and performance go down you
have a higher chance of inhomogeneities
and other things that might detrimental
her cell and this is kind of analogous
to saying when you hook a whole bunch of
cells in parallel you're limited by your
worst cell and in this case you're
limited by your worst region of that
cell and so that's the same kind of
analogy and I think it's kind of cool
and so you can see this for a lot of
different cells so these are actually
getting pretty big so when you're
getting to I don't know if they make
cells this big but one hundred one
hundred that's a meter squared Wow so
maybe cad-tel can get that big actually
they did
look here's for solar out here I'm sorry
oh okay
your module so cells some of the cells
you can see so here cells morphus
sub-module anyhow so the idea is that
you're again limited by your most
effective region or defective region in
the cell and again illustrated by this
idea here is that you have if you take a
cell you split it up into a grid and you
model it as a bunch of like mini cells
operating in parallel you're again
limited by that bad region and so this
looks a little outdated so there's 2006
so this is cell performance first module
performance and you can see that it's
also quite significant one of the other
things that's different about cells and
modules is that you have glass in front
so when you optimize for example in
class we optimize our silicon nitride
coating for an air silicon interface
modules you optimize that silicon
nitride coating for a silicon to glass
interface in the glass which has a
dielectric or index of refraction sorry
of about 1.5 you're automatically going
to reflect 4% of the light so that
light's lost but it does help with your
reflection losses because you now have a
graded index of refraction
so it does reduce some of the reflection
losses from the interface yeah I'm
guessing yes because this is from
Richard Swanson this is Tony Oh slide I
actually I I guess would be yes but I
don't quote me on that
yeah yes so that's a great great
question actually so your modules are
hooked up to an inverter the output of
your solar cells are a direct current
and so you have to convert that to
alternating current and the inverters
are actually rather intelligent they'll
actually scan constantly scanned at very
high frequency where it should be
operating and taking the derivative and
finding where that optimal point is and
so one of the other ideas that if you
have a bunch of modules usually those
are also hooked up in parallel and the
idea is that have instead of just one
inverter micro inverters so small
inverters for each one so that way each
of those are operating at the maximum
power point and I think problem is that
inverters are expensive and the larger
they are generally the more efficient
they are and cheaper can be so I don't
know how far that material has been real
that idea has been realized but it's a
good question
okay so becomes good for any time so now
we're moving on to advanced concepts
which again area that I'm working in
kind of exciting these are ideas that
are very very high efficiency
potentially very low cost and that's
kind of the allure to them in the in
there they're great science and research
projects so they're really exciting to
be in so one of the things that kind of
motivates this work I think you guys
have seen this equation I know I've used
it before but you know that the the
defining metric for the performance of a
cell in terms of its economic cost is
dollars per watt
dollars so dollars per watt peak this is
all defined at your peak Sun
illumination this makes it location
blind right the real important thing
when integrating it on the grid is you
know how much are you paying in terms of
cents per kilowatt hour but to make it
location blind
you put it in two dollars per watt and
dollars per watt is a function of many
things it's how much does it cost to
make the the module itself so how many
dollars per given area
he divided by the insulation four
dollars per watt-peak you'd set that to
am 1.5 or a thousand kilowatts per meter
squared multiply that times your
efficiency and then by your yield which
is a manufacturing parameter so for some
cells where if you can reduce this
number quite dramatically so for example
suppose you decide to go to very very
thin wafers okay for silicon you want to
move to 20 micron wafers let's say which
is something that a lot of companies now
are working on what happens is that
those become very very fragile and when
you handle them and using all these pick
and place operations to move them to
different processes within the cell fab
oftentimes they'll break and so that
yield parameter can come very important
and off via the interplay with this
number here and that's why it's there so
anyhow what this graph is is this is the
dollars per meter squared so the cost of
producing that cell and then you have
this efficiency here and each of these
lines represent a certain dollars per
watt and so I think the do-e has wanted
us to get to a dollar per watt and you
can do that by either producing
incredibly efficient cells around 50
percent which seems a little
unreasonable but and they could cost
five hundred dollars per meter squared
and that would be that would be actually
a cheap panel or the other idea is to go
to very very low cost and little
efficiency and you can try to hover
around in here
and so this nomenclature about to use is
a little outdated but I think still some
people use it although rather loosely
what's known as first generation and
again these terms are milled I've read
papers now that they claim that there
are third generation where they used to
be classified as second generation it
doesn't really matter but the ideas
behind them are still relevant
so the first generation of the single
bandgap it's crystalline silicon still
what's the market leader and they're on
the order of 15 to 20 percent efficient
but they're still relatively high cost
and there's actually a lot of work now
that says that this can move in this
direction moving to thinner wafers
increased laser processing just tighter
manufacturing
can really bring that cost down so your
second-generation are your thin films so
this is either cigs amorphous silicon
organics a lot of these very very cheap
to deposit cheap to manufacture but they
generally suffer inefficiency so they
hover around in this area and so far
this idea hasn't really fulfilled itself
except for maybe cad-tel which is a thin
film material and then what we're about
to talk about is our third generation of
cells so these are potentially low-cost
and potentially incredibly efficient so
we're going to talk about only a few
types today I encourage you to look up
there's a whole different types of solar
cells you can look up ideas that are
research being done on but I'm going to
talk this is what I work on or
intermediate band solar cells
specifically impurity band photovoltaics
and I'm sure you're all familiar with
this picture
but if you want to create free mobile
charges within your semiconductor you
have to shine light on it that has
energies greater than the bandgap and so
you lose these low-energy photons
they're not collected and what's a way
that we can collect these well one idea
is this guy had was if you can create a
material that has a density of States
that looks like this you can create a
stepping stone by putting a half-filled
band within your bandgap that allows you
to promote to that band and then from
that band into the conduction band so
the idea is that your voltage output can
still be maintained for the host
material but you can collect that extra
current so your ISC will increase
substantially and so that's the promise
and if you do some theoretical
calculations similar to what chocolate
in quasar did assuming the radiative
lifetime is your limiting factor
and again that's certainly not the case
in some of the materials that are worked
on for this idea and the idea is you can
actually get up to around 63 percent
efficient and so what this graph is here
here's your single gap limit this is the
calculation similar to what shocking
quasar did I think this is using
blackbody radiation which is why the
curves are so smooth and it can actually
outperform a tandem cell which is again
most
Junction cell that are two cells stacked
and it turns out the best is something
that has a gap level that's about 0.7
evey from the conduction band and has a
larger band gap so the distance between
your valence band and conduction band of
around 1 point 9 electron volts and
that's kind of the ideal material for an
intermediate band solar cell
so theoretically this idea is a great
idea problem is how do you make a
material that has this band structure
that's really the challenge where people
are working right now and it's actually
rather difficult and so there's three
approaches one is the impurity band
which I personally like because it's a
much cheaper method other one is this
band anti crossing idea where you can
actually split the conduction band using
and it's generally done with these mixed
metal oxides and these highly mismatched
alloys and they're really cool and this
is currently the most successful
material therefore intermediate in solar
cells and then there's quantum dot
arrays and quantum structures that are
also a possible fabrication method okay
so idea behind an impurity photovoltaic
is you start with let's say material
like silicon or some other high band gap
semiconductor you put in materials or
impurities that have these deep level
States iron would be an example so iron
and very low concentrations can be
incredibly detrimental but as you
increase that concentration above some
critical limit often called the MOPP
transition limit you can actually form a
band within the bandgap and so the idea
what's going on here is that each of
these atoms has some electron wave
function in some radius that it sees and
then as you increase that concentration
these wave functions overlap and you can
have conduction through those mid-level
states so that's one idea and I like it
because you use very what I could
consider very dirty materials the
concentrations you can put in here
around one atomic percent so your
silicon is only 99.9 percent pure at
this point
other idea is to use either quantum dots
or these quantum wells so these are I
think the idea here is that these are
localized and then this becomes
delocalized so as you bring these
quantum well structures or quantum dots
closer together you can actually get
tunneling through these states and it
basically essentially forms a band
within your bandgap similar idea is to
do this locally is that you have one
photon promote to one of these confined
States in your quantum structure and
then another photon to keep promoting up
into your conduction band to create
carriers
it's usually stacked between two other
semiconductor materials so you have
semiconductor quantum dots semiconductor
if you look up this paper among if you
woke up anything they so Antonio Lou
okay and I'm sorry yeah Luque and Marty
are two people in Spain who kind of
promoted a lot of the theory around this
and look of their quantum dot papers and
they'll really go into the device
structure if you're curious I'd
recommend you a natural portions right
and that's one of the limiting things as
the eqe of these devices because they
can't grow so many are pretty limited
and again these also provide pathways
for traps and other things which is
again a huge problem for these types of
devices and ideas and people are working
on that quite extensively from the
theory side and from the experimental
side and trying to merge the two okay
yeah sorry then it seems to me that they
would act as traps again I'm not an
expert on these types of materials but
ya know that that would be my
inclination I mean I guess the idea is
that you have a very very short well and
then you have a field across it so
there's nothing something else to hop to
and it just pulls it right out so that
would be one device structure again like
these are generally just like a few
layers of quantum dots okay
oh I didn't put up their IQs Deker okay
so this is the band Andy crossing model
so this is with their using these
quaternary alloys so these are again
very very hard to grow and they've done
these awesome measurements where they
can show your valence band conduction
band in your impurity bands and they use
it using a technique called photo
modulated reflectance so basically the
reflectance under oscillating fields and
from that you can get these kind of
resonance points between the different
transitions and you can figure out where
your energy states lie it's a really
cool technique but what they did is
they've done some very very careful
engineering and grown these very very
carefully and they can actually
demonstrate the sub bandgap response
where if they have let's say a photon
that's able to drive this transition but
it's too low in energy to drive that
transition they will get no current out
and then as soon as they add the higher
one it the current will increase and
then if they turn off that low energy
photon source the current decreases but
doesn't stop because the other high
energy photon can do both promotions so
this is actually one of the only
successful devices of impurity been
solar cells and it was quite quite an
awesome feat so okay I think one of the
few ones we'll talk about for another
advanced concept is hot carrier cells
this is something I think Martin green
pioneered and believe is still working
on I haven't heard much about them
recently so I don't know what the
progress is there so the idea is that
one of the biggest losses as I'm sure
you guys know from I think homework 1 or
2 is thermalization in your solar cells
that when you promote an electron well
up into the conduction band it then
thermalized is due to heat and gets re
gives off heat or phonons which are just
lattice vibrations which is another way
of thinking about heat in that process
the problem is that's incredibly fast if
you look at the timescales here so you
come in you promote this electron way up
into your conduction band this is what
it looks like prior at that promotion
and then it slowly decays and that decay
happens over about a picosecond
so if you want to move your carrier in a
Pico
second if you know what your field is
you can see how long that length is and
that Lange scale is also incredibly
short and so one of the ideas is okay
how either we can decrease our path
length or we can somehow slow down
thermalization and that's actually one
idea and to slow down thermalization
it's something that they call carrier
cooling and basically making certain
types of device structures or material
structures you can inhibit certain
phonon modes so when these electrons get
promoted they want to give off heat they
basically give off lattice vibrations so
they want to shake the atoms around them
and distribute those that motion if you
prevent that from happening
somehow through certain types of
structures you can allow that process to
go slower and that's one of the ideas
extracting the carrier is also kind of
difficult
you need to have contacts that are
selective that can take the hot carriers
at all the different energies that they
promote of that and that's also a really
difficult idea and some of the ideas
that they've been working on to these
resonant tunneling contacts so again
this is kind of hairy stuff this has
been I think these slides are rather old
and I don't know what's come of this
research so it's a really exciting idea
and I encourage you guys to look more
into it okay so now we're gonna move a
little bit away from advanced concepts
and talk about kind of bulk thin film
materials I think we actually gonna end
quite early I'm just fine so the most
common commercially available type of
material are these wafer based materials
so mono crystalline which you know which
is what our cells were made out of this
easy or kirovskiy growth
you're probably pronouncing that wrong
silicon multi crystalline silicon which
I think Tony was showing you what that
looks like you can see the different
grains they're actually quite pretty
ribbon silicon which was pioneered by
evergreen and I think now that
technology's gone I've ever green went
out of business so I don't think that
technology is still around
Civello still might be making modules
anyhow so thin films cad-tel is still
currently a first solar still one of the
cheapest modular makers their process
was so cheap and that their efficiency
really suffered because they didn't even
have an A or C coding for the first five
or ten years of development and they
said we didn't need it and they were
right they were still outperforming
silicon people that's becoming less
though the case and the one of the big
problems with cad-tel as you guys know
is the shortage of tellurium and also
the toxicity which some people are
really concerned about other IDE yeah I
I guess so then yes I don't I don't
actually know I do know that cad-tel is
a very stable compound and I know people
who work with it here they actually work
on recycling it so how to dissolve it
and and separate the two elements and
it's they're not worried about the
hazards of the actual raw material
because it's a pretty stable compound
but a lot of people do worry about it
and you know it's it's certainly a valid
concern so but one of the thin film
replacements well amorphous silicon I
think you guys know what that is but
that's deposited silicon it has no real
like lattice structure to speak of its
kind of the disordered mess which means
it has a lot of dangling bonds it has
very very low mobilities as a result or
sorry low lifetimes as a result and also
in because they only has low mobilities
you also deposit in you deposit with
hydrogen to passivate all of those
dangling bonds and that's usually done
with either plasma enhanced chemical
vapour deposition and it's done on
either metal or glass and so it has
potential to be very cheap and then one
of the things that I think was aimed to
replace cad-tel was cigs so copper
indium gallium diselenide I'll get into
some of the problems with cigs in a
second but there are a few startups
around it I think
nan-oh Soler's one Helio volt and I
think Solyndra was one although I don't
really want to say their name out loud
so okay so problem with sig's is if
you're looking for earth-abundant films
again if we want to scale if we want
solar energy to scale to terawatt levels
so if we wanted to provide all of human
energy needs then we're gonna need to
use elements and materials that are
earth-abundant cheap to find cheap to
produce and cigs isn't going to get us
there it's got indium and gallium indium
which is highly used and the prices
skyrocketed now because I think it's
used in your displays and televisions
there's indium in here oh it's I - oh
yeah okay that's where it comes from
then yeah thank you so what people have
been working on are trying to look at
replacements so this is CZTS so it's
copper zinc tin it's sometimes sulphide
this is selenide but they are also
working on replacing the selenium with
sulfur something a little more earth
abundant and this was done at IBM and it
was pretty remarkable actually because I
think within a very very short period of
time they were able to get efficiencies
of around nine point six percent which
for a fledgling material is incredible
and I'll get to why that was so
incredible in a second but again when
thinking about earth-abundant materials
I really recommend you guys read this
paper this is a paper by Cyrus Wadia
it's environmental science technology
and it looks at all of these different
semiconductor materials and it looks at
in yellow this is the what you could get
if you looked at any production of that
of that semiconductor material now in
terms of what is being produced to
produce the raw materials that make it
and then if we the known economic
reserves what can we mine and get
economically today how much could it
produce and your worldwide consumption
is on this line and you can see cad-tel
is just barely eking it out
and the ones of note for this discussion
are cad-tel
cigs which is slightly better and then
CZTS which is rather plentiful now I'm
even with reserves that are currently
being
No and so that's kind of the take-home
message the other thing also really
interesting is the actual raw material
cost cad-tel turns out is not that great
when you compare it to cigs and then
CZTS
it's a whole lot cheaper so one of the
other things about CZTS that's so cool
is that there's this huge basically
there's this huge growth parameter space
for making these quaternary alloys and
IBM on their first shot just kind of
nailed it so they didn't really look at
their whole this whole parameter space
it was just kind of their first first
shot which is right there and so it
might already be optimized and a lot of
people are kind of concerned about that
but I think it's certainly a very
interesting field and really cool to
work in and so I think hopefully there's
hope there so that actually we're ending
way early but that concludes the lecture
today if you guys wanna stick around for
more questions that's totally fine but
that's all I had prepared for today so
thank you
you